sure enough I have to put you on the
spot I don't you to hate me for this but
I heard that on your social media you
admitted to dating someone so why was
now the time to finally answer that
question I'm getting else a question
daily and I never said I wasn't dating
someone but dating also doesn't mean in
a relationship let me just see somebody
join a burgess confirming to EG that she
is in fact dating somebody and when the
time is right she'll reveal who the
mystery man is come on now when it's
real and when it's something that can be
talked about it will be for now she's
focused on heading into the Dancing with
the Stars semifinals with partner Bobby
bones your team won do you feel some
sort of victory over that our team
rocked it how good was that team we
finished and I was like wow we just did
that because it came together so quick
like Sharna and the other pros put that
dance together and we only got to
practice what twice yeah I would never
want anything so it was cool how did you
feel about them tonight I feel like they
were a little bit nicer to you I mean
when really made out with Bobby Oh Bobby
nearly kissed and Bruno - I did I kisses
all around I can't believe I'm making
semifinals and eyebright kiss the whole
audience next week about make the finals
oh dude if we get Jen's what he's gonna
go through all the stands to make out
with everybody when you signed up for
this did you ever anticipate that you
would make the semifinals I didn't know
what that meant
so no no I didn't know what it I was
like I might go do something I'm not
good at it try to get better at it but
no I don't there was no structure in my
mind of what to do win I can't believe
we're here I think it's sad that
DeMarcus went home I think the Marcus
was a prime time top guy and so I'm
shocked by that frankly like really
great out there on the floor I'm so
surprised that it's him how does the
game plan evolve for the semifinals I
don't know I'm just gonna show up in the
morning in 2000 we have to we have to
just put as much work in as we've been
doing and I have to create dances that
are worthy of getting us to the steps to
the finals this one's really on me
there's nothing more that Bobby can do
he's giving me all the time he can all
the hard work and dedication that he can
so this one lies
on me and me only I got to create the
right I also could say congratulations
American Idol you're gonna be the
full-time mentor so what exactly does
that mean well it means I'll be working
with all the contestants on their
performance their singing if they're
gonna play you know so pretty much the
entire Idol performance package so you
know I've got a little bit everything
from TV to radio to music and so they
want me to work with the contestants on
being a well-rounded performer so for me
the fact I'll bring a meal for every
episode is again it's crazy to me is
making this in my finals for Dancing
with a star like it's nice yeah it's
nuts right now exciting time in your
life it isn't it and I have all of my
people to thank for like I wouldn't be
here without the people that listen to
my radio show and that actually vote on
this show and that support us like I
know that I'm not not talented and
without them supporting me I wouldn't be
here
[Music]